nigeria ist ein Land das berühmt ist für
seine Filmindustrie
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja tatsächlich ihr wisst ich ehrlich
alle dass in den und die USA die beiden
Länder sind die die meisten Filme auf
der Welt produzieren und ausgerechnet
Nigeria könnte durchaus an dritter
Stelle der Weltrangliste stehen allein
im Jahr 2022 wurden dort über 2500 Filme
produziert sowie von Hollywood oder
Hollywood der Rede ist könnte also auch
von lollywood sprechen und ich weiß was
sie jetzt denkt nigerianisches Kino ich
wusste gar nicht dass es sowas gibt und
das ist natürlich auch nicht
verwunderlich wir reden hier über sehr
billig produzierte Filme die praktisch
nur in Afrika konsumiert werden aber nun
ist doch ein gutes Beispiel dafür
welches Potential dieses Land besetzt
und wie wenig wir darüber wissen nigeria
ist nicht einfach nur ein weiteres
afrikanisches Land es ist das Land mit
der größten Bevölkerung und der größten
Wirtschaft Afrikas wir sprechen hier von
einer vollwertigen Ölmarkt die das
Potenzial besitzt ein neues Russland zu
werden okay gut ich bin mir allerdings
sicher dass das erste Bild das euch in
den Sinn kommt wenn ihr an Nigeria denkt
folgendes ist
[Musik]
ganz genau es ist leider auch das Land
von Boko Haram das Land in den die
Terrorgruppe im Jahr 2014 nicht weniger
als 276 Mädchen entführt hat nun ja
meine Lieben Zuschauer die traurige
Realität ist nun mal dass ich Nigeria
trotz seines gewaltigen Potentials heute
in einem miserablen Zustand befindet
unabhängig von den Öl Einnahmen Leben
40% der Bevölkerung absolute Armut und
das sind sage und schreibe mehr als 80
Millionen Menschen denn ja nigeria ist
das 7 bevölkerungsreichste Land der Welt
es hat über 230 Millionen Einwohner aber
das ist noch lange nicht alles schaut
euch mal diese Grafik an hier könnt ihr
das erinnert Potential dieses Landes
erkennen es steht was die Einnahmen aus
dem Erdölexport angeht an der 9 Stelle
weltweit und in der Rangliste der Länder
mit dem größten Ölreserven liegt ist auf
Platz 11 nicht weit hinter den USA genau
hier und nicht in betrügerischen
Spam-Mails liegt Nigerias große Schusse
die Europäische Union braucht neue
Öllieferanten könnte einer der
wichtigsten davon werden und jetzt
werden vielleicht einige von euch wieder
sagen oje schon wieder eine Diktatur die
uns mit Rohstoffen versorgen wird nein
ganz und gar nicht dieses Land verfügt
über eine Verfassung und eine
Staatsaufbau der zumindest in die
Theorie demokratisch ist etwas worum es
sich in Afrika leider um alles andere
als eine Selbstverständlichkeit handelt
was ist jedoch mit vielen seiner
Nachbarländer gemeinsam hart sind
Korruption geringe Wahlbeteiligung
eingeschränkte bürgerliche Freiheiten
und schwache Institution die dazu führen
dass die nigerianischen Demokratie als
sehr schwach geht doch trotz alledem
stellt sich die Frage ob die Öl
Einnahmen aus Europa in Verbindung mit
einer Verbesserung der demokratischen
Strukturen die Nigerianer nicht aus
ihrer Armut befreien könnten und könnte
vielleicht umgekehrt Nigeria mit seinen
dinosaft Europas Energiemärkte retten
könnte es für Europa vielleicht jede
Rolle übernehmen die vorher aus Russland
gespielt hat natürlich ohne die damit
verbundenen Probleme die Russland
automatisch mit sich bringt ja eine sehr
interessante Frage und deswegen wollen
wir sie heute be Antworten natürlich
diese oft indem wir zuerst einen kurzen
Blick in die überaus interessante
Geschichte Nigerias werfen also
aufgepasst
[Musik]
ein Land und 250 ethnische Gruppen
von Nigeria haben wir wahrscheinlich
alle schon mal gehört und nicht nur aus
Spam-Emails immerhin ist es das
bevölkerungsreichste Land Afrikas und
das siebbevölkerungsreichste der Welt
und natürlich verfügt es über gewaltige
Ölreserven aber was genau macht Nigeria
eigentlich aus nur Nigeria wird von etwa
250 ethnischen Gruppen bewohnt und jede
von ihnen hat ihre eigenen Tradition und
sprachen die Hausarzt
dieburgers und hunderte weitere sind
über das ganze Land verteilt als die
Briten in der Mitte des 19 Jahrhunderts
hier ankamen und ein Kolonialregime
errichteten dauert es nicht lange bis
die Unterschiede zwischen den regionalen
ethnischen mehrheitsgruppen deutlich
wurden
tatsächlich teilten die Briten die
Kolonie in drei Regionen auf den Norden
der haushaar und der muslimischen fulani
den ickbo Südosten und den jurubas
Südwesten der hauptsächlich christlich
geprägt war und was meint ihr haben die
Briten alle drei Regionen gleich
behandelt nun ganz und gar nicht das
Lieblingskind des Empire in der Kolonie
war der muslimische Nocken wo die emiere
den britischen Streitkräften im Tausch
gegen Luxusgüter bei der Sicherung der
Kolonie halfen nun ja es war die übliche
imperialistische Geschichte teile und
herrsche am Ende nachdem sie genügend
Unheil angerichtet hatten entschieden
sich die Briten dafür Nigeria 1960 die
Unabhängigkeit zu gewähren aber nicht
aus purem Guten willen sondern weil es
bereits viele Aktivisten Gruppen gab die
zu sehr darauf trägten und ihnen das
Leben schwer machten z.B die Action
Group und der National Council of energy
area und nicht zuletzt die Kameruner ihr
könnt euch sicher vorstellen dass ein
Land das ich aus 250 ethnischen Gruppen
zusammensetzt gewisse Probleme mit dem
inneren Zusammenhalt haben wird die
vielen Menschen mit sehr
unterschiedlichen Hintergründen werden
Schwierigkeiten haben politisch einen
gemeinsamen Nenner zu finden und dies
führt zu vielen Konflikten ich habe
genau das ist auch in Nigeria passiert
und auch nach der
Unabhängigkeitserklärung hat es nicht
lange gedauert bis es soweit war schon
sechs Jahre nach der Unabhängigkeit fand
der erste Staatsstreich statt seitdem
versickt Nigeria im Chaos bis zu 6
Puschel zwischen 1966 und 1999 und
ständige Spannungen zwischen dem
islamischen Norden und dem christlichen
Süden wohlgemerkt es gab nicht nur
Staatsstreiche sondern auch einen
ausgewachsenen Bürgerkriegen
1967 kam im Norden das Gerücht auch dass
im Osten des Landes Bewohner des Nordens
ermordet worden wären die Moslems im
Norden wurden darüber so wütend dass sie
dort lebenden Angriffen und massakritten
außerdem vertrieben sie viele der dort
lebenden in ihre Herkunftsregionen also
den Osten dies führte wiederum dazu das
noch im selben Jahr Oberstdorf wo die
Unabhängigkeit der östlichen Region
unter der Flagge der Republik Biafra
erklärte zunächst sah es so aus als
würde ein unabhängiges Bier Erfolg haben
schließlich war die Region die
ölreichste in Nigeria doch der Traum von
Unabhängigkeit und Ruhe verwandelte sich
schließlich in einen Albtraum die
islamisch dominierte Regierungstruppen
umzingelten Biafra es war vollkommen
isoliert das Ergebnis war eine
schreckliche Hungersnot an der täglich
mehr als 3000 Menschen starben darunter
ein Drittel Kinder jeden einzelnen Tag
Hunger ist eine Kriegswaffe und wir
haben die Absicht die gegen die Rebellen
einzusetzen AIDA Leiter der
nigerianischen Delegation bei den
Friedensgesprächen in die Armee im Juli
1968 am Ende nach dem über 2 Millionen
Menschen verhungert waren kapitulierte
bierfrau und wurde wieder Teil Nigerias
wohlgemerkt Nigeria hatte damals nur
etwa 50 Millionen Einwohner wie ihr euch
also vorstellen könnt haben die Egos
diesen Konflikt dieses Trauma bis heute
nicht vergessen doch trotz alledem
begann sich die Situation 1999 zu
verbessern nach dem Tod des Diktator
begann in Niger ia die sogenannte
Republik
[Musik]
nach mehreren gescheiterten Verfassungen
und Republiken die vollständig von der
Armee beherrscht wurden schien die
vierte Republik neue Hoffnung zu bringen
im selben Jahr wurden Neuwahlen
abgehalten die der Sohn des ehemaligen
Diktators ober Sancho gewann und seitdem
haben bei den aufeinanderfolgenden
Wahlen nur ober Sanchos Auserwählte
gewonnen die alle der demokratischen
Volkspartei angehören der wichtigsten
konservativen und wirtschaftsliberalen
Parteien des Landes allerdings spielte
sich das alles nur mit massiven
Wahlbetrug und mit politischer Gewalt
und Unterdrückung gab dennoch gelang es
der nigerianischen Bevölkerung 2015 eine
Machtwort zu sprechen schaut euch an
Nigeria Wahl mohammado buchari gewinnt
Präsidentenamt so sieht aus meinem Leben
Zuschauer im Jahr 2014 schwenkte das
nickianische Volk nach links und wählt
den Vorsitzenden der Oppositionspartei
in Sozialdemokraten Mohammad du buhari
und warum war das eine gute Nachricht
nein nicht weil wir diesen Politiker im
Speziellen für sympathisch halten oder
so was dies war viel mehr zum ersten Mal
in der Geschichte die gerias eine
sicher macht Wechsel mit anderen Worten
es sah ganz danach aus als würde die
Demokratie in diesem Land tatsächlich
endlich Fuß fassen die Frage ist also ob
sich dieser Trend fortsetzen wird na was
meint ihr hat die demokratische Wende
dafür gesorgt dass die Gewalt zurückging
und Nigeria für seine Bürger sicherer
wurde oder ehrlich schreibt uns doch
schon mal jetzt einen schnellen
Kommentar was ihr tippen würdet und aus
welchem Grund wir lösen diese Frage dann
im Laufe des Videos auf aber bevor es
soweit ist würde ich euch gerne eine
kleine Botschaft in eigener Sache
überbringen zum einen geht es darum all
unseren edlen freiwilligen Spendern in
aller größten Dank für Ihre
Unterstützung auszudrücken eure Beiträge
sind nicht nur wichtig damit wir unsere
Videos produzieren können nein jeder
Euro von euch motiviert uns natürlich
tausendfach mehr als das was wir mit der
Werbung einnehmen allerdings werden wir
ehrlich gesagt leider leider ohne die
Werbeeinnahmen total aufgeschmissen ja
mit Spenden alleine könnten wir uns
finanziell leider nicht über Wasser
halten und deswegen würde ich an dieser
Stelle auch noch gerne eine das Ganze
für unsere Sponsoren brechen hier müssen
nämlich auch verstehen dass es ganz und
gar nicht selbstverständlich ist dass
jemand Werbung schalten will die mit
politischen Content verbunden ist ganz
viele Marken schrecken davor einfach
zurück dass sie darin eine Risiko sehen
das gesamte Umfeld ist ihnen nicht
werbefreundlich genug und deswegen
würden wir euch gerne darum bitten
zumindest bei uns das vollkommen
natürliche Gefühl des genervtseins durch
Werbung zu unterdrücken denkt doch beim
nächsten Mal einfach daran dass es genau
diese werbe dran sind die dafür sorgen
dass es unsere Videos überhaupt gibt und
dass ihr sie euch ansehen könnt ja genau
diese nervigen Werbetreibenden und
natürlich unsere Spender klar wäre es
uns lieber wenn wir mit den letzteren
ausgehen aber bis dahin sind ist eben
die ersteren auf die wir angewiesen sind
also habe bitte etwas Geduld mit
Unverständnis für die Werbung bei uns
denn auch wenn sie euch nicht direkt
anspricht bringt sie euch ja indirekt
auch viel und den Spenden mit da und von
ihr unabhängiger machen können findet
ihr natürlich wie immer in der
Beschreibung unter den Video als kleine
Motivation für euch haben wir in diesem
keinen Sponsor integriert überlegt euch
also ob ihr Spenden möchtet und lasst
uns dann fortfahren und die Frage klären
ob sich die Dinge in Nigeria seit der
Demokratisierung zum besseren oder eher
zum Schlechteren gewendet haben spitzt
die Ohren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das Russland Afrikas
im Laufe der Jahre hat sich die Geria
zum führenden Exportland für dinosaft
aus Afrika entwickelt tatsächlich
produzierte es zwischen 2015 und 2019
mehr als zwei Millionen Barrel Rohöl pro
Tag um euch eine Vorstellung davon zu
geben Angola an Nigerias in Afrika
exportierte 2019 nur 1,4 Millionen
Barrel pro Tag wir könnten also über ein
wahres afrikanisches Russland sprechen
1977 dem Gründungsjahr der staatlichen
Ölgesellschaft baut Nigeria seine
Exportwirtschaft auf dem Saft der
Dinosaurier auf tatsächlich wurde das
nigerianische Erdöl aber schon viel
früher ausgebeutelt
1937 als Nigeria noch eine britische
Kolonie war begann die britischen
Ölfirmen Roll das Shell und British
patrolium das Gebiet nach Öl abzusuchen
im Jahr 1953 fanden sie schließlich
kleine Mengen die sie allerdings noch
nicht gewinnen bringen verkaufen konnten
im Jahr 1956 sollten Sie doch Ihre erste
kommerziell nutzbare Förderstätte für
das Flüss schwarze Gold erschließen es
befand sich in der Stadt alloy biri in
Niger Delta dem ölreichsten Gebiet des
Landes die Unternehmen wussten dass Ihre
Investition abgesichert fahren also
beschlossen sie mit der Raffination des
geförderten Rohöls zu Beginn im Jahr
1965 erbauten sie die erste Raffinerie
und von da an kamen weitere Unternehmen
hinzu Chevron und Texaco aus den USA
sowie die italienische Arche
und ich ahne was ihr jetzt denkt was für
eine Glücksfall und eine Reibach für die
Ölkonzerne nicht wahr daran kann
schließlich kein Zweifel bestehen wir
sind es gewohnt dass sich die Energie
Rohstoffe fest in den Händen des Staates
des exportierenden Landes befinden und
das ist zum Beispiel im heutigen
Russland und schon lange in Saudi
Arabien der Fall auch wenn sich diese
beiden Staaten eher im Privatbesitz
einer Mafia bzw von Portal Herren
befinden gut trotzdem in Nigeria sind
die Dinge noch mal wesentlich flexibler
ja theoretisch gibt die aktuelle
Verfassung dem nigerianischen Staat die
volle Kontrolle über seine Natur und
Energie Rohstoffe aber die Realität ist
vollkommen anders die Politiker und
Beamten in Nigeria haben nie davor
zurückgeschreckt mehr Nutzungsrechte
gegen saftige Bestechungsgelder zu
verkaufen
[Musik]
kein Wunder also das ist in Nigeria 159
Ölfelder und 1.500 Förderanlagen gibt
und natürlich gehören viele davon nicht
dem Staat die meisten von ihnen gehören
ausländischen Unternehmen nach Angaben
eines ddrianischen Öl Investment
Managers befinden sich 98% der
Ölreserven und Betriebsmittel des
Sektors in den Händen von 6 westlichen
privaten Ölgesellschaften von den Shell
die wichtigste ist und nicht nur das
Shell exonic Chevron Agip und hexagro
besitzen bis zu 6 öl-export Terminals
und mehrere Pipelines und jetzt denken
sich ja viele was für ein Neo
Kolonialismus da haben wir es wieder
westliche mega Konzerne wollten ein
armes afrikanisches Land bis auf die
Knochen aus tja dazu kann ich nur sagen
macht euch nichts vor die nigerianische
Regierung ist auch nicht dumm nigeria
hat ausländischen Unternehmen nicht
erlaubt die gesamte Produktionskette zu
kontrollieren die Raffinerien gehören
nämlich dem Staat erinnert ihr euch an
ihrer Familie die Shell und BP 1965 zu
bauen nun der Stadt kaufte sie ihnen
1978 ab und fast alle großen befinden
sich mittlerweile in staatsgesetzt
tatsache ist das Öl zum größten Export
gutes Landes geworden ist es macht mehr
als 70% aller auslandsverkäufer aus gut
aber was bedeutet das nun alles nun was
ihr sowieso alle Politik schon länger
guckt könnt ihr euch durchaus vorstellen
was es bedeutet ganz genau Korruption
vielleicht erinnert ihr euch noch an das
Video zum Fluch der Rohstoffe der
holländischen Krankheit dass wir vor ein
paar Monaten auf unserem schwesterkanal
wieso alle economic veröffentlicht haben
all die dort angesprochenen Probleme
finden sich wie in einem Brennglas
ähnlicheria den Link zu besagten Video
findet ihr natürlich in der Beschreibung
unten Nigeria wird von diversen
Problemen rund um den Ölsektor geplagt
es wird euch nicht überraschen wenn ich
euch verrate das eine der größten
Geißeln Nigerias die Korruption ist und
zwar nicht nur irgendeine Art von
Korruption sondern spezifisch die
Korruption im Ölsektor und wenn die
Auswirkung der Korruptionen Nigeria
nicht so außerordentlich groß werden
würden wir euch nicht einmal davon
erzählen aber Tatsache ist nun mal das
mehr als 20% des beep genau aus diesem
Grund den Bach runtergehen um euch eine
Vorstellung davon zu geben mit dem was
das Land durch Korruption verliert
könnte man seine gesamten Staatsschulden
abbezahlen das Problem ist aber das so
gut Politiker als auch Geschäftsleute
von der Korruption in diesem Sektor
extrem profitieren um euch die Dimension
mal zu verdeutlichen die ehemalige
nigerianische ölministerin diese man
wurde zum Beispiel verurteilt weil sie
zugelassen hat das nicht weniger als
verwandt sich Milliarden Dollar aus der
Jury national companya verschwunden sind
der reichste Mann des Landes und
vielleicht ganz Afrikas der
Geschäftsmann aliko dann gute würde
ebenfalls beschuldigt im Jahr 2003 vom
ehemaligen Präsidenten und Sancho gibt
weil ich keinen Verkauf zu haben
die Korruption hat dazu geführt dass die
dekoreanischen Bürger oft keinen
einzigen Cent vom Verkauf des Landes zu
sehen bekommen nach Angaben der Weltbank
hat nur ein Prozent der nigerianischen
Bevölkerung vom Ölsektor profitiert aber
jetzt haltet euch fest denn das ist
nicht nur eine schlechte Nachricht für
die Nigerianer sondern vor allem für die
Ölfirmen selbst in vielen Teilen
Nigerias fangen die Menschen nämlich
deswegen an Förderstätten zu verwüsten
und Treibstoff aus den ohnehin schon
baufälligen Raffinerien und Pipeline zu
stehen
[Musik]
deshalb überrascht ist uns nicht wenn
wir auf Nachrichten wie diese stoßen
Nigerias
illegale oder affinerin dreckig
gefährlich lukrativ in vielen Städten
und Dörfern z.B megadet da stehen die
Menschen nur Öl und beschädigen dabei
die öl-infrastruktur für viele von ihnen
ist das die einzige Möglichkeit in einem
Land mit einer Arbeitslosenquote von 33%
bei jungen Menschen sogar 54% über die
Runden zu kommen die Korruption hat
sogar dazu geführt dass selbst viele
Gemeinden im Süden des Landes Ruhe
stehen und selbst Raffinieren doch das
ist nicht das einzige Problem schaut
euch mal das folgende an
ein Fail state
erinnert ihr euch an Biafra jener Region
die 1967 versuchte ihre Unabhängigkeit
von Nigeria zu erlangen als ich euch
vorhin erzählt habe dass die Xbox nicht
vergessen hätten was während des
Bürgerkriegs geschehen ist meinte ich
damit dass viele von ihnen auch heute
noch ihre Unabhängigkeit befürworten
tatsächlich haben die Egos Separatisten
ihre eigene militante Organisation die
Nigeria auf der schwarzen Liste der
Terrorgruppen steht und wisst ihr warum
nun weil die nigerianische Regierung sie
auch beschuldigt Rohöl zu stehlen und
Raffinerien zu sabotieren denn der
grassierende öldiebstahl im ganzen Land
hat die nigerianischen Staaten
Milliarden an Einbußen beschert einige
Schätzungen geht davon aus dass sich die
kumulativen Verluste aus Diebstahl
Sabotage und den daraus resultierenden
Produktions rückgängern seit 2008 auf
100 Milliarden Dollar belaufen könnten
da ist es nur logisch dass die Regierung
des Landes und internationale Investoren
besorgt sind aber die Egos Separatisten
sind nicht die einzige Terrorgruppe im
Land ganz im Gegenteil tatsächlich ist
sie noch nicht einmal die blutdruckste
um die Wahrheit zu sagen die am meisten
gefürchtet von allen haben wir bereits
erwähnt und ihr kennt sie auch schon
Moko haram
Boko Haram wurde 1995 als gewaltlose
muslimische Jugendgruppe gegründet als
sie jedoch im Laufe der Jahre
feststellten dass die Entwicklung in
Nigeria den Wünschen Allahs völlig zu
widerlief begann sie einen blutigen
Kreuzzug und zwar um das Land in einen
islamischen Staat zu verwandeln indem
die Scharia gilt denn wer nicht
freiwillig konvertieren will muss eben
dazu mit Gewalt gezwungen werden um es
an dieser Stelle deutlich zu sagen wir
haben es mit einer Bewegung zu tun die
eigentlich tief ins Mittelalter gehört
sie hat in einer modernen Welt überhaupt
nicht verloren und bekämpft sie auch
sogar ihr Name Boko Haram bedeutet
übersetzt Bildung ist Sünde nun ja die
Organisation selbst gibt eine deutlich
längere Übersetzung an westliche
Zivilisation bzw falsche und islamische
Erziehung ist verboten nun ja unabhängig
von der Samantha kann man mit Bug und
Recht behaupten dass diese Terrorgruppe
offensichtlich kein Freund davon ist das
Mädchen die Schule besuchen dürfen und
um ihre Ziele zu erreichen griffen sie
ab 2002 zu äußerst gewalttätigen
Methoden ihr erst Ziel war die Stadt
maidoughuri aber ihre Ausbreitung begann
recht schnell auch im Rest des Landes
vor allem im Nordosten Nigerias aber
erst 2009 wurde sie so stark dass sie zu
gefürchteten Terrorgruppe des Landes
aufsteht und so eine der blutrünstigsten
in der gesamten Sahelzone und das meine
Lieben Zuschauer soll verdammt noch mal
was heißen denn dort geht es wahrlich
nicht zimperlich zu wir haben über die
brutalen Zustände in der seilzone sogar
mal ein eigenes Video gedreht und ich
werde euch natürlich verlinken in jedem
Video erklären wir euch wieso die
Bevölkerung des heilzone allein schon
ausgeografischen Gründen extrem geplagt
ist und das religiös ideologische
narrativ von Boko Haram spricht die am
stärksten benachteiligten
Bevölkerungsschichten des Landes an vor
allem in mehrheitlich muslimischen
Norden und auf diese Weise ist es ihnen
gelungen mehr als 40.000 Kämpfer zu
rekrutieren
aber wartet ein Moment das ist noch
lange nicht das Ende der Fahnenstange
Boko Haram ist wahrlich nicht die
einzige Terrorgruppe die Nigeria plagt
wird man einen Blick auf diese Karte
neben den Problemen mit Boko Haram und
der asphaltungsbewegung für wer war ist
in den nigerianische Regierung noch mit
weiteren offenen Fronten konfrontiert
von den Banden im Nordwesten des Landes
über die Abspaltung der Jehova im Süden
wie die von Biafra bis hin zu den
Konflikten zwischen den muslimischen
Hirten und christlichen Bauern der sich
quer durch das ganze Land zieht
26 April 2023 neue Morde in Plateau
Demonstranten verbarrikadieren den mit
Leichen 16 Mai 2023 Nigeria mindestens
30 Tote bei Zusammenstößen zwischen
muslimischen Hirten und christlichen
Bauern die Region die an der Trennlinie
zwischen den mehrheitlich muslimischen
Norden und den mehrheitlich christlichen
Süden Nigerias liegt hat seit Jahren mit
ethnischer und religiöser Gewalt zu
kämpfen die Gewalt in Nordwesten und in
der Mitte Nigerias hat sich von den
gegenseitigen Tötungen vor der
umfassenden allgegenwärtigen
Kriminalität ausgeweitet bei der
schweren bewaffnete Banken doch für
Überfallene massenentführung begehen und
plünder im April wurden fast 50 Menschen
getötet als bewaffnete Männer ein Dorf
im benachbarten Bundesstaat benoe
Angriffen wobei die örtlichen Behörden
den Hirten die Schuld gaben benoe gehört
zu den Bundesstaaten die am stärksten
betroffen sind von zusammenstoßen
zwischen Landwirten und Hirten die
beschuldigt werden mit ihren
Rinderherden Ackerland zu zerstören ist
Nigeria also ein Feld state ein
gescheiterter Staat die meisten
Analysten haben keinen Zweifel daran es
ist eine
wenigerianische Regierung hat keinerlei
Kontrolle über das Gebiet das von Boko
Haram beherrscht wird sie vermag auch
nicht nennenswert in den Konflikt
zwischen Hirten und Bauern einzugreifen
in diesem Fall handelt es sich um einen
Konflikt der seit 1999 mehr als 20.000
Menschenleben gefordert hat es gibt
jedoch auch noch viele andere die nicht
zu sehr auf die Kontrolle des Staates
über sein gesamtes Hoheitsgebiet fixiert
sind deshalb haben wir auch Analysten
angehört die lieber sagen dass sie sich
nicht um einen gescheiterten staatsan um
einen scheiternden Staat handelt was
ähnlich klingen mag aber nicht völlig
dasselbe ist und diese behaupten auch
das Nigeria aus drei Gründen anfangen
könnte zu funktionieren es gibt heute
mehr politische Stabilität es gibt mehr
Toleranz zwischen den ethnischen Gruppen
und es gibt eine stärkere nigerianische
nationale Identität einige Trends sehen
also durchaus positiv aus es bleibt
jedoch eine Tatsache dass die
nigerianische Regierung auch heute nicht
in der Lage ist ihr gesamtes
Staatsgebiet zu kontrollieren mit
anderen Worten ja nigeria ist unserer
Meinung nach der Zeit ein gescheiterter
Stadt aber wird er auch Bescheid dann
wird alles nur noch schlimmer nur die
Dinge könnten sich ändern ausgerechnet
der Krieg in der Ukraine hat diesen Land
eine neue Chance eröffnet und natürlich
werdet ihr euch jetzt fragen was
bitteschön hat das was in der Ukraine
passiert mit Nigeria zu tun nun hört
euch mal diese Nachricht an laut Kreml
will Russland Ölverkäufe unter der
Preisobergrenze verbieten Moskau sei
bereit die Produktion zu drosseln und
die exportverluste zu kompensieren sagt
er stellvertretende Ministerpräsident
Alexander Nowak russland will kein Öl
unter der europäischen Preisobergrenze
an die EU liefern und das bedeutet eines
europa braucht neue Lieferanten für
dinosaft und genau das könnte eine große
Chance für Nigeria darstellen die Dinge
auch bei sich zu ändern darüber hinaus
ist die Qualität des nigerianischen
Saudi arabischen Rohöl sehr ähnlich das
heißt es ist von bester Qualität leicht
zu raffinieren kann in den gleichen
Raffinerien verarbeitet werden und ist
relativ billig zu fördern Nigeria könnte
also damit beginnen die Bohrtürme
anzuwerfen und ohne Ende Erdöl zu
fördern allerdings gibt es doch ein paar
Probleme die diesen Traum gefährden
könnten
der Hauptgrund ist dass ihre
Tagesproduktion von den Fördermengen der
OPEC plus abhängt und in Anbetracht des
jüngsten Trends wird diese ihre
Produktion wahrscheinlich weiter senken
um die Preise weiter in die Höhe zu
treiben außerdem wird die ausrufernde
Korruption im Land diesen Traum
weiterhin unmöglich machen je mehr Geld
gestohlen wird und je weniger bei den
Bürgern ankommt desto mehr Diebstahl und
Sabotage wird es geben und das heißt
wiederum weniger Geld für die Regierung
es ist eine Art Teufelskreis und
schließlich befinden sich die
Raffinerien und einige Pipelines in
einem erbärmlichen Zustand die vom Staat
eingenommenen Öl Geld erwerben durch so
viel Bürokratie und Korruption
verschwende dass sie Instandhaltung der
öl-infrastruktur oft fast nicht
vorhanden ist und ihr schlechte Idee
Infrastruktur desto geringer ist
natürlich auch die Produktion nigeria
hat natürlich bereits einen ersten
Schritt zur Lösung dieser Probleme
vollzogen indem es eine gewisse
demokratische Stabilität erreicht hat
bei den Wahlen Anfang diesen Jahres
wurde der Partei Kollege boharis zum
neuen Präsidenten gewählt worauf nicht
nur die Finanzmärkte positiv reagiert
haben
wichtige Rolle bei der Gründung der
aktuellen Regierungspartei all
progressives Congress kurz APC in der
sich 2013 die drei größten
Oppositionsparteien vereinigt hatten die
Wahl 2023 fiel ziemlich knapp aus aber
die nubu versprach im Vergleich zu
seinem Vorgänger einen neuen forscheren
Führungsstil und dies weckte viele
Hoffnungen die Sicherheitslage in den
gerea hat sich verschlechtert der neue
Präsident Nigerias bola Ahmet wo hat
versprochen die Sicherheit zu einer der
wichtigsten Prioritäten seiner Regierung
zu machen in seiner Antrittsrede
versprache unter anderem das Personal
der Sicherheitsorgane besser auszubilden
auszurüsten zu bezahlen und mit mehr
Waffen auszustatten eine kürzlich
durchgeführte Umfrage ergab dass ich 77%
der Nigerianer in ihrem Land unsicher
fühlen die Sicherheitslage nigeria hat
sich in den letzten acht Jahren
verschlechtert alle Regionen des Landes
sind davon betroffen die Daten zeigen
dass es zwischen den 29 mai 2015 dem
Amtsantritt von Präsident wo Harry und
dem 18 mai 2023
050.279 Todesopfer durch
sicherheitsrelevante Vorfälle dem stehen
34.66 Todesopfer gegenüber die zwischen
den 29 mai 2007 und dem 28 mai 2015 zu
beklagen waren zwischen Januar und Juli
2022 wurden bei 2.840 gewalttätigen
zwischen Fällen mindestens 7.22
Nigerianer getötet und
3823 entführt dinobus Vorgänger bohari
hat eine Reihe von Versprechung gemacht
um Nigerias chronische
Sicherheitsprobleme zu lösen aber er hat
es nicht geschafft sie wirksam anzugehen
tja und damit wäre unsere Frage vom
Anfang des Videos wohl beantwortet nach
der demokratischen Wahl wo Harry ist
Nigeria noch unsicherer und noch
tödlicher geworden als es zuvor sowieso
schon war natürlich wollen und können
wir hier keinen kausal Zusammenhang
herstellen aber der Trend ist klar und
leider auch ungebrochen das morgen gegen
den auch nach timbus hoffnungs und
kraftvoller Antrittsrede weiter
9 juli 2023 Plateau über 200 Menschen in
Mango in weniger als zwei Monaten
getötet das folgt der Mango das im
Bundestag Plateau lebt hat die
rinderhirtenvereinigung im Yeti Allah
dafür geeignet dass sie verlassene
Gemeinden in Weideflächen verwandelt und
Jagd auf vertriebene macht um das Land
zu übernehmen und was will tenobo nun
konkreter gegen Unternehmen nun zunächst
war vor allem das ziemlich lange
Schweigen des neuen Präsidenten
bemerkenswert und als er sich dann
endlich äußerte forderte er war die
harte Bestrafung der Täter und ihre
hintermit ist jedoch die Urheber der
meist von den islamischen Hirten
ausgenommen Gewalt klar zu benennen
schließlich will er seine
Stammwählerschaft nicht vergessen die
novo verurteilt die Mörder in Platon und
ordnen Verhaftung der Täter an der
Präsident ließ die Sicherheitsbehörden
auch an dafür zu sorgen dass die
Hintermänner der Mörder verhaftet werden
und die volle Hälfte des Gesetzes zu
spüren bekommen eine der hauptfolgen des
immerwährenden Konfliktes ist immer der
tragische Verlust von unschuldigen
Menschenleben der Aufbau starker
friedlicher und wohlhabender
Gemeinschaften erfordert Toleranz und
Vergebung für jedes vermeintliche
Fehlverhalten so die nubu der Präsident
forderte die religiösen und
traditionellen Führer der Gemeinschaften
soziokulturelle Organisation sowie die
Führung des Ariva consultate Forum der
jar Martin Islam und der Christian
Association of Nigeria auf sich
gemeinsam für die Förderung eines echten
und dauerhaften Friedens einzusetzen es
bleibt also abzuwarten ob der Moslem Tim
wo wirklich willens und in der Lage sein
wird das Problem an der Wurzel zu packen
und eine wirkliche Trendwende weil er
sich immer weiter verschlechternen
Sicherheitslage im Land herbeizuführen
denn die wir die Geschichte nicht kennen
würde ist uns nicht überraschen wenn es
erneut bei schönen Worten bleiben würde
während die Gewalt weiterhin tobt oder
Islam seine aggressive Expansion mit 230
Millionen Einwohnern
bevölkerungsreichsten Land Afrikas und
vermindert fortsetzt wir werden die
immer am Ball bleiben und euch
rechtzeitig informieren vergesst also
bitte nicht das Abo mit Glöckchen falls
nicht schon erledigt und danach seid ihr
erst mal mit eurer Meinung an der Reihe
habt ihr vorhin richtig getippt oder
nicht und hat euch das Ergebnis des
Demokratisierungsprozesses hinsichtlich
der Sicherheit Situation überrascht wird
Nigeria es also schaffen der Korruption
dem Terror und der religiösen Gewalt ein
Ende zu setzen könnte es Russland als
Rohstofflieferant für die EU ersetzen
und wird es dem riesigen Land gelingen
auf diese Weise die Lebensbedingungen
seiner Bürger zu verbessern einem großes
lebenswertes Land in Afrika zu werden
wie immer sind wir auf eure Diskussion
zu diesem Thema schon mächtig gespannt
ich hoffe dass euch dieses Video
gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht auch was
dabei gelernt habt falls ja gebt uns
bitte ein Like teils mit euren Freunden
und diskutiert es mit ihm natürlich
freuen uns auch wie gesagt jederzeit
über eine Spende von euch dieses Projekt
weiterzuführen den Link dazu findet ihr
in der Beschreibung oder dem Video
mach's gut und bis bald
[Musik]